long last I never told you this but when
I was advised keeping yeah more times
than I can count
he would say I only been here man
Allison we never had students like so
yes thank you being here thank you jack
Thank You colleagues and everyone lives
oh of course and so Alice that
congratulations book which is wonderful
in which I was very proud to get to say
my two cents worth about on the book
jackets I will repeat myself except the
state Supreme even everybody we survived
afterwards of when you slightly funny
yeah and I'd like to start with the most
general kind of opening of the subject
question which is how did you come to
this topic it's such a great idea
why well I can't explain this crap you
know every year I see the sophomores at
the end of the year all excited
I know
they look different you know different
interior it's a kind of confidence it's
an intellectual so I decided I would
look at the women who really made the
most of that experience and figure out
who these heroes of study abroad for the
icons who are the women who transformed
us in the first one that was a very
personal connection because when I was
in fifth grade learning French
I took the imaginary man
Jack Kennedy who was in the white house
within white house and was really
in front of speaker to all little girl
from Minnesota United
so she was the first one and then the
others followed creaking
Sontag who really trans
to us in the 70s and 80s
with
both structuralism anything as an Angela
Davis is probably the most surprising
morning to people the most difficult
story to battle out and in really in her
case it's that she affected grown up so
much in session
and that's a great story and it's a
great reversal of expectations
yeah I know and it's wonderful you know
what I mean I like that you really
highlighted beginning in your book is
that we're all quite familiar with a lot
of the stories of well-known men and the
formative experiences that they had in
the paragraphs and so what do they mean
to you in particular - because I did you
learn in college a particular need to
ask but the students I see where honor
always women and so what could it mean
for you two to sort of greet them that
way and to limit yourself action
decision apparently 75% of all freshman
interests are we
the other thing that I said in the
beginning in the book the male
experience story as is as familiar as a
right to move and the women's stories
are really harder to classify it's not
just about going and getting drunk
inside young man you know with our fight
with
if something that's a little harder to
describe to glamorize Jack Kennedy
herself is very eloquently she talked
about
taking her notes and the whole notebooks
with this sort of pagers answer the
delicious pleasure of discipline
sitting must be off if there's no one
it's a quieter yeah yeah
I think so and the stories are so
beautiful when you read them one after
the other and partly because you've got
this great sequencing kind of
chronologically speaking which is
Jacqueline Kennedy goes in 1949 49 1950
it's Paris as you know
yeah the buildings haven't been cleaned
she still has a ration card through
coffee and sugar so there's a senior
national retired it's really exciting
it's so close to the war she lives with
a concentration camp survivor
yeah she really the confessed the whole
team would survive her brothers
worksheet and
in an aristocratic branch of the
resistance
there were lots of arrests because these
strategy weren't really grated as you
know
but she she wanted to forget about all
that and she took Jackie Bouvier to set
up by the seal of course
received all collections she took her to
the loo and she was a widow her husband
also died
no that's I think one of the one of
their really again fascinating things
about the book is this sort of the
texture and nuance of these women's
experiences though so far behind the
kind of altruistic associations we have
with Americans in Paris if you talk to
us a little bit maybe about each woman
in the tea that Jacqueline Kennedy on
the heels of the occupation
you've got Susan Sontag in the middle
theology more republic and in which what
she doesn't read and then you got answer
the Davis in the in the aftermath about
it as you say having this big effect
back on the current elections in
particular so can you tell us a little
bit about changing to have what the
French call that song bro use and period
of the rise from World War two
as lords but also the incredible
tensions of decolonization
so
me to tell that history from the point
of view of these three women
Harris turn figure
was all about but experiencing it
according to the dreams they brought to
Paris
so for Jacqueline who J she had to get
her
family like the pretty depressing family
life the poor little rich girl and we're
persistent Suntech she was a runaway
ships a runaway from a marriage she
married too early to die and she had
gotten herself to oxford fellowship and
a couple months at Oxford and she just
took a little boat race of Marys
never never get everything really went
to the single class weird that
she sits inside a we think as such
here's a little
she never mentioned what she
so that was bad
I think when you manage maybe you're not
thinking about the fall
you
this was implicit in what you were
saying before about senior students go
abroad and come back different that was
there something important to you about
this particular stage in life for these
three women that kind of 1921 day
they're on the cusp of something
different and the hinge of France and
freshness to help shape their sort of
buddy
but it's such a great age 20
you're starting to see what you can do
with your life what you
so as the beginning it's just on the
cusp of everything
and to find yourself in a foreign
country
I went to Santana so the story I like
best about Angela Davis's is her high
school experience she's she's walking
around Birmingham with her sister and
they go into a into a shoe store it's
Jim Crow Birmingham and they pretend to
be French girls from my famiiy and it
comes in you know 19 - 1960 or something
it Trump's Jim Crow they are served at
the front of the ship store
she after you know 10 or 15 minutes of
the charade starts laughing and says ha
ha I'm not for luck to you actually it
was a scary story it's a terrifying
story about courageous yeah yeah but the
mountain meets being movie follows her
through her time and she goes to she's
in and she's not from a rich woman from
Nazi need that she pretended to eat but
from very poor family of immigrants and
that kind of raises something else they
didn't touch on throughout the book
about them these women all went as our
students certainly do went to France
with certain expectations that there
were certainly kind of aspects of French
life or fantasies of French culture or
French identity that that each one of
them brought with her and she went and
so could you talk a little bit in I I
laughed a movie exception because I I'm
distantly related to the movies and in
our family it's never been something
that we were proud of the movie is
actually not you know Jacqueline and it
made a lot out of very little in terms
of that particular ancestry subjectively
we had
can you tell a little bit of a story
than what it wasn't on tagging maybe
more about what it meant
I think we have too simplistic an idea
about what the fantasy about yeah yeah
so projector booth
grandfather made
yes gave them a fake genealogy book and
told them they were descended
and in fact she was descended from a
French soldier and Napoleon's army who
had to escape from them from the white
terror and ended up in
and got rich really fast I mean I think
yeah
generations Susan Sontag called herself
a self-created European she came from
the most middle middle dusty Arizona
background
married a retired captain in the army
and she was in
Robin
Hollywood high with everyone off going
to going to drive-ins and listening to
rock and roll I apparently amused me
because of course in Paris at the same
time there's Johnny Holliday pretending
to be Elvis dress
and for Angela Davis you know there's a
huge cultural expectation for African
Americans in that period
and because of all
and also certain
disappointment one
France is a racist country they
certainly certainly gentle data so that
plus just remembering
policemen hosing
when you talk about the kind of
the self-created European that is such
an amazing statement what was it that
each of them got from France that sort
of enhanced the European side of their
image and again in Daisy saving or what
they should get back to France with can
you talk a little more precisely about
that exchange in each case well true joy
from the future Kennedy that she had I
think that is a French town her life I
mean she would love your work for
example she was reading seem all she was
really improved on a campaign rally can
imagine her
trail and she had cruised behind her to
understand all the jealousy you know
you know but she could have written you
know that reading Lolita in Tehran but
and so furniture was prettier in your 70
healing of the main enchant effect and
everything aspect and also a real
defense against the Canada I was on the
radio and Dublin the other day and I had
a sort of stopped myself as I was saying
well she could defend herself against
the Irish no just culturally
today it wasn't always easy she was
attacked constantly in the press with
the Frenchman enemies about Hannity
called up the secretary and said - what
are these French menus you know
not this way that's being to frenching
yeah it turned out the White House is
really full of French furniture the
original
yeah so the idea that taste was in her
kind of refined taste is something that
you know she probably fresh she wrote
all these lips and I wish might have
found more than the cheese just sit down
and write totally unstudied letters with
simply adorable trendy mistake she wrote
to booth all home she was a model she
arranged with a novel of the brand was
source mother took to Atlanta she said
she wished she'd been hired Whistler
stay over there but she had a really
good time given the huge constraints on
women of that generation she managed the
cableway
and I don't you feeling ever
you could see that
yeah and let me talk quickly and then
I'd love to kind of move on to Tucson
tagging and Davis and that same question
of what they took away but there's one
story I really love in your book many I
love about her later in life and some
contact that she had with Susan Sontag
when specifically as an editor and
has to do drug enough with herbs and can
you tell that story because it says so
much about something scientific not
particularly appealing way of poignant
way about how much Sontag wanted to be
important
she's the scrappiest of them you know
she said she didn't have the money to do
what study abroad program so she had a
bacon
but anyway in the in the New York
publishing world citizens and Jack
Kennedy was Jack Kennedy Onassis was now
an editor at doubleday and this is circa
like it's after is a massive debt by
this point yes and then Onassis we had
and so Jackie Kennedy Onassis needs a
blur
she needs a blurb for Diane Greenland's
beautiful book of photographs and she
writes I should really write other the
most heartfelt letter requesting this
board from Susan Sontag was published on
photography and is considered great
erudition
of photography Susan Sontag doesn't even
rank for she has Roger stress right back
saying it's almost like night I'm sorry
I have to wash my hair yeah there you go
here's her letter and in the letter back
and this follows her quoting from a
letter from a French publisher saying
that writing angrily the Susan Sontag
saying in all of my decades as a
publisher in France you're the only
author who's never bothered to write
back to me directly once and that's
always through your American editor
through your agent so it would be
NASA's voice it would be so deeply
appreciated if you could give a quote
for it if you could see the different
ways for original tweets photographs
cropping layout juxtapose anchor or the
photograph should remember to put here
that we have like eleven photographs his
passing steamer looks like a lease for
an elder Maxwell
calles and her husband in dot dot in her
nightclub is pure Bolivian I believe I
think they'd better be pulled off this
book soon as I
please forgive me I want to do
everything I can to make it a success
for her she is a gallant figure to whom
I'm devoted and it is a great book and
inside
Jackie then project stress refund
I felt that mrs. Onassis in the book
explains that the citizen had handed him
her letter in the material with one foot
on the plaintiff all I did phone to tell
you that she's sorry she cannot comply
for besides everything else she has a
standing rule not to comment on any
quote picture books but this of course
has to do with her book on photography
and I'm sure and she is sure that you
will understand
but but yeah the happiness you have a
youtuber kind of a nice lip gloss on
that when I saw tagging on the
psychology contact area do you see that
somebody the French stories and she
you know and for her to be able to be
theoretically of the marketplace was
both truly obnoxious and
yeah and how did you see that you know
in addition to the great Marian she's
got she was a love affair with the
Rothschild Washington Paris about yeah
that was a really funny story to dig
into yes she fell in love with a woman
named me close and if any of you have
seen the film
Fonterra she plays for the Sister Sister
of those mad she also plays the daughter
in C monster down man
she was a Rothschild would change her
name to Niko State College had been in a
resistance she was discovered by Hannity
after the war she had a really nice
today in the 16 images that sonntag off
with a really nice reading space and it
was
fantastic relationship for sonntag
because in this person because Stefan
was everything that would interest her
it was the experience of the resistance
it was a French Jewish one it was an
incredible culture and then eco
statement spent much of her life trying
to get a movie of the first produced I
mean it was like her Alesha
finally if I wonder did that
but yeah but so is prasanta so there's
there's a social dimension of decency
because he said over time there as you
indicated before it's certainly not the
kind of political orgasm all that's what
is happening former Washington parents
what was it for her what did she what
happened to her in in Paris love and and
what else
it was very anywhere he was very private
I mean I think it was partly just you
know and it was also time to read and it
was
very strange that she did she invented a
French method she in her archives of
UCLA there are long these notebooks
notebook after notebook of worthless she
organized the whole French language by a
theme so she's got but any really
specific and unusual word lists the
nuances of words about love how to argue
how to wash yourself how to buy this
they've ever seen somebody in there
really really interesting things like
Napoleonic Code and then indeed respect
by the last and certainly not least I
mean what because you talk about all the
men with certain presuppositions of
course about friends which one generally
has in some form rather especially that
sitting the alternative approach my
imagination is positives you've got a
usually book but but what we're so
there's the Martinique in a variant
social political experience that
obviously she gets because when she's in
in the urge in the beginning
church bombing go back home can where
friends are killed and as the Kennedys
so she has an education
recorded
in the French press and
president you shocked movie The Herald
Tribune and wire service accounts of the
Birmingham bomb it's just deeply deeply
racist I was really shocked and then of
course it's the same time in which you
know the French government has to
so really really interesting to read the
news
for that generation that generation
they're all they're all into protests or
read it's not
she she rides in Paris an existentialist
and she left we all got a parasitic cyst
into her she's been reading canoe she's
been reading a lot of stuff and she
perhaps this is shocking she left a fan
of the new novel
I can't
yeah yes yeah well the view and
interpret of it because obviously that's
because as far away as you can get from
this kind of literature political
engagement well the thing we really live
which when she was in prison
whoa create signed a petition took her
because what we is really famous for
saying you know the only revolution that
all the
- oh he was their petition with Picasso
I love that you could go to France and
study all these writers within
March no that's a bad that's a way to
start talking to back about what her
head was on French intellectual culture
have to explain to this audience the
circumstances
led to her going underground father
Merrin County shootout the gun was
registered to her that were strong
yes she was underground 418 no she
wasn't around unsure how many months but
she was then in place
for 18 months awaiting trial
and murder and during that time she had
been a member of the channel book club
which was a an African American branch
of the Thomas
and during that time the French
Communist Party went to bat
if you were in trouble in those days you
wanted the French colonies totally
organized
did an incredible job organizing they
turned out 60,000 people to march for
her one weekend in October the year of
her trial and we have documentary films
of those marches it's fantastic I mean I
think of it as the French discovering
identity politics because there are all
these signs she is black she's a woman
she's a communist it was really forcing
them to rethink some of the terms
that's wonderful mmm and then of course
you know there's a whole canon of work
that involves Angela Davis probably the
best-known book is either they saw that
by Dynomax me where Angela day
and George and Jonathan Jaxson are
characters but they're also characters
going back to the toast slave revolt
so they reoccur they were like reborn
now so in terms of identity politics
that's one kind of in yeah the kind of a
rethinking of Republican universalism
that stuff what do you think Jacqueline
who you know President Kennedy talks
about himself as being a man who company
what what if anything similarly did to
Jack intend to give back to the French
what did Susan Sontag contribute given
action yeah better they never would she
give them well obviously
preserves and I love the more convinced
that they were related to her
you know I think that for Jacqueline
Kennedy it's just the fact of the first
lady being friend
huge huge huge huge importance that that
linguistica master
Chris isn't Santa of course she became
the prototypical American real actual
again and again there's all this press
coverage of her
she's the New York intellectual she was
too American for the French and to
French
she she planted herself as a French
writer in the US in some ways yeah
and wasn't her it was just levels of a
basic fluency with her French probably
the worst
all your friends are here so well I'd
say Angela Davis gets up in 18 over 20
okay the things you can't really judge
Susan Sontag speaks French fearlessly
with no regard for intonation or accent
whereas junkie was very careful and
whispering you know
so each I'd say each of them was a
pretty faithful translation of
themselves
it's so much fun to go to the
audiovisual room of the French library
and listen to these old TV shows and
tapes
French press descending on Jackie
Kennedy to ask her about the Sorbonne
Angela Davis on Avila's talk boom out
people had a brilliant idea to put her
across right in the seat next to Gaston
whenever he and I don't know if any of
you know that's what guess when one of
you represents the the Frenchman from
Cayenne who was the ultimate Republican
he was the president of the French
Senate he was second in line to the
French presidency
and was seated next to Jacqueline
Kennedy at one of these state dinners
when she was in Paris so I loved it you
know I I tried to have a few little
intersecting moments like in the desc
pathos
so honey that's who
that's to first jet one can
yeah what are their yeah you know that
I'm formally I'm very interested in that
is the idea doing the triple stricted
how was that what's been somewhat
challenging the structure because from
the start there's nothing like these
women we sort of imagine what
together what they wouldn't have to talk
about so I like the idea that there were
three different terraces for them don't
you know
also I like just looking for
and so a person makes
so she's going to bet she's visiting
basser and Smith
the year before Jeff one Indian dressed
appearance and she is looking at these
American college girls sitting in their
chance you know irony shares in their
blue jeans and she's thinking this is
the greatest and all of these girls are
just done
and that's the perfect yeah I would
cross and she's important for Sonntag as
well Suntech goes to hear her speak in
the south line about novel writing and
non tech say oh she's got such a sweet
voice some type of already thinking that
she she's gonna see you know already
imagining herself as a writer
manager Dallas Dallas because you see
the wonderful visual documentation of
this work and then we'll open up the
floor to questions from
the other kids call out Laura Maris's
here who was my research assistant and
which one was the view on which one was
the
and which one was Sabine de July the
woman looking right at Genelia Symington
alive of course is the descendant of the
famous
do i who dressed Marie Antoinette she
crossed the river to me come
Paris Rory for feminism one part though
era she had a condition through new
world through banking
there was a grinning fretfully guy
really you know really relaxing to talk
to it what I imagine is that it was very
different than what manageable yeah me
well this is your singing contest a
confident attitude
I'm sorry I said yeah this kind of
social side of her time and then of
course when she becomes first lady the
newspaper also digs up a version of this
old photo and tries to reveal the true
Jackie
yeah oh this photo I love because it's
probably the only photograph of Jackie
who did it before she had to pose when
she couldn't really just ham it up she's
on the banks of the wall with her most
sister even travel around she doesn't
have to worry about being this
but here at summer
you can see her as the very tall and
cross the bridge with some Suntech kind
of hurrying behind the ketchup and
yes
this is strange I'm going through some
people in the film world that citizens
on Titan had a walk
like selling and there she is all proof
we need factory and she's instead see
multi-pane this modern furniture gallery
on what about Sandra
she just needed to make money
stranges she's never referred to this
and she was our three as critical
that story about the day she was a in
this anybody here from the Columbia
French Department this is a sort of a
Jeopardy question do you recognize a
well-known French professor in this
photo
it's Angela Davis in
Howard block and people who work in the
world of French studies really get to
keep out of the fact that Howard block
was Angela Davis's best friend on a
study abroad it shows a slight change of
style for Angela Davis Yakima who fought
before
this is she she by now she is a
philosophy professor at UCLA Georgia meg
comes to UCLA to speak in support of the
Black Panther Party during the tour and
she translates for him when he gives his
lecture that was a
don't trust this I loved in the in the
archives at UCLA
we're sorry in the art hazard Stanford
for boxes and boxes and boxes postcards
that any of us received from French
French children
yeah I was organized by these school
teachers you know who we're teaching her
stories so this is for you today
you later
these things and they're on catalog
so here's Angela baby she's just
published her autobiography it's
appeared in British translation she's
come over
watch in 1975 and she is one of us club
there she is with the great Gaston
and they're having an argument about
race and Dustin will know because sandy
is never experienced races
I was the sort of restraint with which
she listens to him in the respect she
shows when as he's telling this you know
the story
and she said well
you know I'm an exception
oh this is very legible
well this is a story of a mistake on my
part but in the state that I love so
right
research Jacky's host sister crowed done
this Holy Grail out of an old shoebox
she said Jackie wrote a poem she wrote a
bilingual
all these years and here it is and I
just thought this was wonderful because
I knew
relationship with the language and you
as a sign
- well when the book was reviewed in the
Wall Street Journal last week the critic
who was quite distinguished
in juvenile but vengeance would soon be
had a wonderful blogger named
poetry blog figured out that this was
not Jackie's religion
it was the Johnny Mercer Hoagy
Carmichael song
how little
translate
please don't leave the master traffic
what is it without the special knowledge
of myself
what prize do the most about you to go
through with just there's so many
surprising things about all that at
least for me these are all that most of
us have a fair number of preconceptions
we think we have a fair amount about all
of them what let's shock do you most
ready
maybe shock isn't there a surprise you
we fall in love with each one
yeah so I think the chaplain John
she was so resilient and she was such a
you know I had met her and I think I
always thought about it's just the kind
of the faux French this of the
the movie was in our lap and
yeah and
how hard she had a struggle to get that
she really is she was she said right
that she was a self
you know and courage
surprisingly but there was something
about
that's it
it's a shock when you see it in
somebody's
well I